I want to start with the sincere uh
congrats on the movie I thought you did
a great job with the material thank you
so much I really appreciate and I
appreciate all the bad boys in your
background
all for you I said
thank you
um so I like throwing a curve at the
beginning uh if someone has actually
never seen anything you've directed
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
that's a good question
um the contradiction thing in my work is
probably that I'm educated the
screenwriter you know I should be a huge
fan of imagination and yet my own
imagination seems to be the most boring
thing I can think of I am obsessed with
the world around me I'm obsessed at
looking at details
in in the world that I live in and try
to find ways to tell stories that can
learn us something about living a human
life in this world and that that has
been my my my project ever since film
school I remember when I started as a
screenwriter I remember thinking that
the best dialogue I could find was from
documentaries and that that kind of
states it perfectly
um I um I need
reality like naturalist not classic
European social realism but naturalism
seems to be the engine uh in my work
before I get into talking about the good
nurse I am a huge fan of Mind Hunter uh
I think it's the best thing Netflix has
ever made uh I just love that series
um can you just talk a little bit about
being part of it and getting to work on
such a special series oh I was so
blessed I was trained a screenwriter I
never been on a film set before I
directed my first film
um and and I was used to shooting in a
very Scandinavian dog my way with a
handheld camera where we would just
throw it around and then suddenly
Fincher a big hero of mine called me and
asked me to join him on mindhunter and
um I saw it as an opportunity to to to
go back to film school and you know
really learn from the best
um so I went over and part of me going
over was to direct two episodes but also
follow David Fincher on one of his
episodes and I was able to sit there and
take notes and make drawings of how he
placed the camera and how that whole
thing worked and I truly learned a lot
from it
um on many levels and also I learned how
to be able to focus on a big American
set instead of these small Scandinavian
sets I was used to so I I owe David and
mind Hunter a lot and it was a pleasure
to work on it yeah I mean what's funny
is how many people would pay to be in
that situation to watch Fincher work up
close I know I I felt blessed and and I
sat there you know I had no idea how to
block a scene back then so I would sit
in the hotel room at night you know just
making drawings and trying to understand
the logic of why and how the camera and
the the actor what that relationship was
like
um and and slowly slowly that craft grew
on me jumping into why I get to talk to
you one of the things that's interesting
is that in the film you never explain or
try to explain Charlie's motivations
you're it's me it's you know it's from
Jessica's point of view
um and it's unusual because you know
most Hollywood movies are always trying
to offer more and get into the weeds um
can you sort of talk about why you
didn't want to show that because I I
personally think you made the right call
well thank you and and listen I think
that you and I as human beings we have a
need to bring order into chaos and to
try to understand the unexplainable
um but it is unexplainable and I don't
think that any reason would have made
sense I don't think that anything
Charlie could say would actually be
believable I don't think that there is
one good reason that he did this
um clearly it's a very uh damaged human
being that ends up doing something this
evil no doubt the question for me that I
found interesting was not about Charlie
it was about how the system allowed this
to happen year after year I think that
was the big question mark that needed to
be raised not trying to be find a
fascinating reason for Charlie to do
this but how and why did the system not
stop them yeah watching the film I got
very angry because the worst part is you
know this is price still happening uh
people that are should not be in
positions like that are probably still
there because of you know the American
Health Care System well I wouldn't even
only blame it on the American Health
Care System I'd say I'm from I'm from
Denmark and we have a totally different
system and yet the systems that we build
also seem to turn against us and forget
its Humanity in some way to try to
protect itself and um and and and and
that's the whole reason to make this
film is to remind everybody of the
responsibility we as individuals carry
in these systems we need to speed up we
need to take action like Amy did and we
need to believe in the value of humanity
even though uh the systems seems
inhumane I love talking to directors
about the editing room and the editing
process because obviously it's where it
comes together so how did this film
possibly change in the editing room
based on any friends and family
screenings or early screenings my one of
my best friends Adam Nilsson the editor
of this film as well
um and I we've been working together for
the last 15 years and I was lucky enough
to bring all the material home
so we sat in my office in Copenhagen and
edited this film
um far away from anybody and at the time
and was giving the time to find the
story that or to refine uh the story
that we wanted to tell I think what's
most struck me was that
the less
of
Charlie's Darkness we showed
the DACA he became
and that was an ex an interesting
journey in in in in in in in Eddie's
portray
um the opening was a little different
there was a little more to it in the
planning and in the way we shot it
but we ended up deciding just opening on
that zoom in on Eddie like not really
knowing what was going on clearly
inspired by uh the opening shot of the
verdict where Paul Newman is playing
pinball machine and slowly the camera is
just moving in and we're realizing oh we
have to look at this guy we don't know
why yet but he's going to be an
important part of the story
um and and that allowed us to
we were interested in Charlie at the
point but that allowed us to not focus
on his Darkness but focus on him solely
as the friend that Amy really needed and
that became even clearer in in the edit
I read that you shot a lot of stuff in
order
um why was that important to you uh to
to do that you know I think the the
access here are clearly great they can
do anything
um but yet
um the logic of this story was like
there was two parts one was the part
where Amy didn't know that Charlie was a
killer and was a friend and then there
was a second part where she knew and the
question was how would she deal with
that and what we did was we we shot the
first half
almost in sequence and then we would
shoot the next half almost in in
sequence uh not completely because of
covet we had to shoot out some locations
but
and nevertheless it was important for me
so that both I the cinematographer the
way we Shot the movie and the actors
completely understood the logic of what
was going on in front of us
um what we would do was we would
increase the amount of close-ups and we
would go closer and closer as we got
into the part where Amy knows that
Charlie's the Killer and we would be
more observant in an armed length
um in in the part where she didn't know
so the whole way we shot it was kind of
dictated on where we were in the story
and the only way to really do that was
to try to keep it in sequence on that
note I need to stop I'm just going to
say congrats on the movie and I look
forward to whatever you're doing next oh
I'm appreciate it thank you so much sir